hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast
and i'm just checking in on you
i'm specifically just checking in
on the state of oklahoma how you go how
y'all doing out there
how are them again cowboy hipsters in
tulsa
um how the [ __ ] you guys doing you know
something
you guys are going to get a lot of [ __ ]
with that math stuff and i wanted to
give you [ __ ] but i actually read on
this and it's it's
starting to make sense to me so the
oklahoma state department oh jesus bill
are you going political too why not
everybody else seems to be doing it you
know if everybody's playing disco you
know
i'm going to [ __ ] play disco all
right the oklahoma state department of
health
held a meeting on monday after hearing
testimony from state and county leaders
on the state of covet 19 response
so they was basically talking about if
they
mandated not requesting
or requiring you to wear a mess
mandating saying you must
wear a mask somebody in charge there
because when i first saw the story it
was just like yeah we're not [ __ ]
doing that and
my first response was to yell at the tv
great then if you get it
they shouldn't [ __ ] treat you and you
should die in the street
you [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] one state
dragon the other 49 down [ __ ] right
that was my first response but now i
actually read a little bit
i read one article uh basically it's on
fox news 23
so who knows um
it was saying that basically the person
was
where is this it's such a great [ __ ]
quote
which of course now i'm not gonna be
able to find
um
oh god damn it this is why i suck at
[ __ ] all right wait a minute here we go
the guy person basically men of the
woman said i do not recommend a mask
mandate i recommend mass
compliance fry says
and he this person said i had multiple
people
tell come up to me and tell me hey i'll
wear a mask
but don't tell me i'm going to wear a
mask
then i'm not going to do it
i'll [ __ ] put one on if you ask me
nicely you
you slick suited [ __ ] don't you
come on my property
and tell me what the [ __ ] i have to do
all right now this here is the
difference between people who live in a
city
and then live basically on their own in
the middle of [ __ ] nowhere all right
you live on your
you live in a city you know whatever you
need you call a guy
and the guy comes and he [ __ ] does it
i got a pool i need a pool guy i got a
lawn i need a lawn guy
my [ __ ] roof's leaky i need a roof
guy well that doesn't go
it doesn't wash in oklahoma
all right if you got one of your [ __ ]
stairs out there
and it is banging into another one
[ __ ] up your meat to sell it market
you can't go out and just call a guy to
come down and take out that [ __ ] cow
steer man you got to do it yourself
these are do-it-yourself [ __ ] people
they got a leaky roof they're going to
fix it themselves you know
someone comes in their house they're not
calling the cops they got the gun
they're taking them out they're feeding
them to the pigs and they're going back
to bed
you know i'm finishing uh a marathon of
manics
on me tv like i do um
yeah i get it now these people are not
idiots they just like i i respect the
hell out of that
you if you ask me nicely i'll wear a
mess but don't [ __ ] tell me you got
to wear a mask that
that is healthy that is a healthy
uh questioning and keeping authority
arms length all right let's let's not
get this twisted you [ __ ] work for me
you
you you [ __ ] ask me nicely
[ __ ]
you asked me nicely and i'll wear it
okay don't come over here like you're
[ __ ] running [ __ ]
governmental sons of [ __ ] i got just
as many guns just as many guns as you do
don't ever forget that and i'll [ __ ]
use them
all right you didn't train me either my
dad taught me before as ever in the
marine corps
so uh i respect the hell out of that it
is as long as yeah i hope you guys
comply
and you [ __ ] do it and uh
you know because the federal reserve
needs you to be healthy and go back to
work so this ponzi scheme doesn't
collapse
[Music]
i gotta tell you man the crazier this
country gets
the better chance of survival all of
these people that liberals make fun of
have okay and i'm i'm not talking about
you [ __ ] conservative [ __ ] with your
laptop
in your little luxury apartment i mean
the real
deal people like everything they have is
camouflaged
like the [ __ ] dish towel to dry off
the dishes is camo i'm talking about
those [ __ ] people
that could you know they know how to
anything that [ __ ] moves they know
how to track it
kill it prepare it and [ __ ] eat it
store it dig a [ __ ] hole in the
ground come back 20 years later remember
where they left it
pickled whatever the [ __ ] they do those
people are going to survive they don't
need
money okay
they can literally sit there and be like
wait we're gonna act like it's we doing
the 21st century thing
you want to go back to the 18 [ __ ]
century i don't give a [ __ ]
i know how to do all of that [ __ ] you
know
people in the cities are like oh my god
my [ __ ] internet is out i'm so
[ __ ] past
i do that every week on this podcast how
much paying money do you have to [ __ ]
pay for the [ __ ]
yeah that's a city dweller i am done the
second
the money system collapses i however
long you can survive
without water because it never rains out
here and then i'm [ __ ] you know
because god knows i'm not trapping i
want to eat some [ __ ]
i don't know diseased coyote out here
so shout out to people of oklahoma this
city slicker here would love it if you
would if you would
comply you know it'd be nice if you guys
wore masks
it seems to be working cause i gotta be
honest with you evidently it's exploding
out here in la
and i don't know i i it seems like if
you just wear a mask you're okay
you know i have no idea um
so anyway you see this is a deal dude i
i [ __ ] i like people i'm trying not
to [ __ ] be a [ __ ] i'll tease you but
i'm trying not to be a [ __ ] here
um and with that
let's see here let's look up trump meets
with top
election advisers as biden's lead
endures this is the thing there's even
if he won this thing there's no [ __ ]
way they're going to give it back to him
they can't do it because then they got
to start turning over all these rocks
and they're just going to find a bunch
of [ __ ]
on both sides dude if they do this if
they really do a recount
right which i guess they're doing i
don't know by hand it's like well how
did you do it the
first time people were mailing [ __ ] in i
would just
did you would you shoved it into a
computer
um here's
if you do a recount and on your recount
you get a different number
then you got to do it again okay and
then if there's [ __ ] lawsuits
and people start looking under all the
i'm telling you it
both side it's not good it's like it's
gonna be like when jim irsay
investigated the pats and they found out
that the cults were doing exactly what
the patriots had done
allegedly or whatever whether it was
done on purpose or whatever whether
there's the weather the pressure in the
ball outside
there was under inflated balls on both
sides
now if you're a trumpster you're going
to argue
that donald trump is the patriots where
everybody's just hating on him because
he's a [ __ ] winner
and joe biden is the colts now granted
the colts also wear blue so maybe that
maybe that is a good argument
i have no [ __ ] idea but i'm just
saying at the end of the day
all right i i just don't think that
they're not going to give it to him
um there's a part of me for the comedy
of it
being a part of the contrarian party
um watching all those liberal idiots
dancing on the side of the street it
would be [ __ ]
hilarious just for that that they did
that dance and then they
uh you know psych you didn't win
that [ __ ] would be funny um it wouldn't
be good for the country but it would be
funny
it would be funny um i don't know what's
wrong with me
what is i i've always as as long as i
can remember
i remember when i was a little kid
when i would see another little kid that
i didn't know fall down and cry it made
me happy i just thought it was funny
it's because i was already a little
miserable bastard
i remember well into my 20s and 30s if i
was in a grocery store
and i saw some kid fall down he cried
and his mother ran over
and kissed him and hugged him and gave
him support it used to make me angry
and i would think hey [ __ ] [ __ ]
and it wasn't it was jealousy i think
that that's what it was
and then if i saw a kid whining
asking for something and then the mother
said no
and made the kid cry more it used to
make me happy and i'd start cracking up
laughing
just watching the kid you know not
because i'm really happy it's just uh
there's just certain things that just
you relate to them so they're funny to
you like that story i always told that
time i don't know if
how long ago i told this story i'll tell
it again one time i was on a plane
one time well just one of zillion times
i was on a plane i'm on this plane
and i'm riding with my lovely wife and
she's sitting in the aisle seat and i'm
sitting in the middle seat right
it's not really a middle seat when you
sit next to your wife because you can
kind of [ __ ] spill into her seat it's
fine you got the arm up
right and um
oh no i'm sorry she was in the middle
seat that's right i was on the aisle
that's right
so i'm watching this movie as my wife is
sleeping
and something happens i'm watching on
the laptop and something happens
in the movie that makes me laugh so
[ __ ] hard
i'm literally leaning into the aisle i'm
laughing so hard
not only do i wake my wife up the woman
on the other side the one who has the
window seat
is laughing at just how hard i'm
laughing like you ever see somebody
laughing so hard you don't know what
they're laughing at you just start
cracking up
that's how hard i was laughing so my
wife wakes up
and she's laughing what are you laughing
about and i'm i'm trying to cover the
movie i'm going nothing nothing she goes
what do you
let me see let me see and i go you're
not gonna like it
and she spun around she saw that i was
watching precious
and she [ __ ] starts punching me in
the shoulder which courts made me laugh
even harder
and i wasn't laughing
that this poor chick was going through
all of that [ __ ] it's just
the mother said something so [ __ ] it
was so mean and then they cut to her
face
and she looked so sad i just
i laughed i don't know why i don't know
what the [ __ ] is wrong
i remember when i went to go see
slingblade
and when uh dwight yoakam [ __ ]
zoomed the guy in the wheelchair out of
the heck you know once you go home and
practice
randy and he [ __ ] zoomed that guy
out the door in the [ __ ] wheelchair
i'll never forget it because at the time
i was in the middle of an acting gig
this is a long
[ __ ] time ago and and slingblade was
in the
uh movies and i had gone to go see the
movie
with a couple of people that were also
on
in this short film that i was making
that never saw the [ __ ] light of day
right
and they were reacting the way you were
supposed to react
when you saw somebody whose legs work
[ __ ] pushed somebody out a door
in a [ __ ] wheelchair and they were
reacting they were and i was
dying laughing and
i remember them looking at me sort of
smiling but looking like what the [ __ ]
is wrong with this guy and that was the
first time that i
realized that actors and comedians were
wired differently we're both [ __ ] up
trying to be good people but we're
definitely wired
where i think the way they're wired is
they like they feel things that other
people feel
not even saying they're in touch with
their other their own [ __ ] but they can
it's how that's why they're so good at
acting you know
we're a comedian we just sit there
walled off and and laugh at [ __ ]
even if we empathize with it um
i don't know what does this say what
does it say about anything what does it
say
about me you know what the [ __ ] i did
i went out and i bought this these two
belts
went to a store and i bought these belts
and i went up to register and when they
wrung it up i could not
[ __ ] believe how expensive they were
it was ridiculous but i hate shopping so
much that i just bought him anyways
you know i really want to be like i'm
not [ __ ] paying that but [ __ ] 20
belts
it's just [ __ ] leather in a metal
buckle what the [ __ ]
but then i got to go to another store i
gotta get back they got a [ __ ]
thing with the card [ __ ] it and these
[ __ ] things
broke down just as fast as any old cheap
ass belt
so the belt broke and i brought it over
to like a a [ __ ] uh a
cobbler a shoe store thinking that maybe
they could fix the thing and then
no we can't we can't do it it's just
just you know it's like i bought a house
at the top of the market i'm just never
to get my [ __ ] value out of that
goddamn belt
i was [ __ ] pissed too when i went in
there because somebody goes i'll just
bring it to a shoe store
they'll and i go they'll fix it yeah
they'll fix it
and i get in there no we don't fix belts
i'm a cobbler i work on shoes you
[ __ ] idiot go go go to a belt store i
was like all right geez
you're going to yell at me you know and
he picked up one of those little hammers
that you [ __ ]
nail a heel back on his shoe he [ __ ]
started waving the thing around
it became a situation um
i don't know i've been seeing some [ __ ]
go out of business it's disturbing but i
think it's because of amazon not because
of covet
you know when you see like a big like
superstore
go out of business you're just like uh
i thought you were the guys that were
[ __ ] had their foot in the back of
everybody's neck isn't that amazing
though
you gotta hand it to that [ __ ] pesos
guy whatever the hell his name is
um
pesos right something like that whatever
bezos pesos
i like basils we'll go with basils right
that [ __ ] guy took an online store
and just blew past
[ __ ] target walmart
sears roebuck
j.c penney marshalls
jordan marsh filings basement
tom mccann mammoth mart
right all the super stores sorry i had
to go back there for a while
child world toys r he gets guy [ __ ]
blew past all of them
you don't even know where his story
where is his store where is all the
stuff
where the [ __ ] i can literally get
anything from a kid's bicycle
to like a [ __ ] scale to weigh cocaine
if i'm a drug dealer
from these [ __ ] people
to a refrigerator a a [ __ ] tarp for
your car
what else do you want huh you want that
little thing that you know kids play
with behind the door then
little [ __ ] thing that stops the door
from hitting the wall they got that [ __ ]
too they got it all they got they
literally
they have everything
all right and then you combine the fact
that they turned our food
into poison all right and you got these
people just like on the sugar and salt
right
just [ __ ] mainline in it you know
they're having a light night which means
they're just eating the vanilla cookies
you know what i mean because it seems
like you know it's almost like a lighter
leaf
cigar you know or maybe it's racist
like why do the oreos have to be the bad
ones bill
you know considering you're you're
you're now
in a racially mixed family unit here
you'd think that you'd be a little nicer
about oreos
um these [ __ ] people they're sitting
at home
all right and they're eating cookies and
[ __ ] pre-made rotisserie chickens
lemon garlic right they get the salt
through the roof then they just start
shoving those sleeves of cookies in
right
the keebler elf [ __ ] and all of that and
then what used to happen is late at
night
they needed to go out and buy something
which was that website people at walmart
or something like that and just the way
these people were dressed
the gang green the broken flip-flops
the the the wasted potential
that you just saw just shuffling
into these [ __ ] superstores all right
and then this website website started up
this page
people at walmart or something like that
and they shamed these [ __ ] people
you know and i think that bezos besos
guys he goes
you know what i think that there is a
market
out there for people that just want to
keep buying
[ __ ] but don't want to be seen buying it
talking about the agoraphobic obese
people
that on odd days of the month eat the
regular oreos
on the even days they eat the blonde
oreos and on holidays they eat double
stuff
and these [ __ ] people need pocketees
they need flat screen tvs they need all
of this [ __ ] and this [ __ ] guy
started a business
to cater to people and now these people
don't have to go out in public
right you know it's like that movie
precious i was talking about right all
these precious people
going into the [ __ ] walmarts getting
shamed
you know wearing some giant purple
something
people calling barney the dinosaur they
don't have to do anymore they can just
[ __ ] stay home
from the comfort of their own home they
can order whatever they want and because
this basos guy saw this [ __ ]
before the walmart people they were just
like hey these [ __ ] people there we
crushed their downtown we crushed
their mom and pop stores we buried them
we buried them the way the white man
buried the native americans that were
here first we continued it on now we
buried the barriers
who can bury us we have 900 000
square [ __ ] feet and guess what he's
gonna turn that place into the
bezos guy is going to turn all those
[ __ ] walmarts
into uh uh the most epic [ __ ] uh
maybe skateboard parks or laser tag
laser tag skateboard
something or other like i don't know
what you're going to do with all of
those things
they're all going to go under there's
not a goddamn thing anybody can do about
it unless somebody
puts down those oreo cookies
and figures out where that [ __ ] guy
lives and takes him out
doesn't take him out like i don't want
to encourage anybody do anything crazy
you know what i mean
just do give him the ddt some sort of
wrestling finishing move
you know if you can get your [ __ ]
flabby leg up that high
oh [ __ ] i went to a mom-and-pop
mexican restaurant that i've been
meaning to try forever
and you go in there as a white dude and
he just the first thing you do is you
try to find
you know you look around to be like is
it a bunch of other white people are
there mexican people eating here and i
went in there all i heard was people
speaking uh
is it espanol is that how you're
supposed to say spanish
people from spain speak spanish we don't
speak whatever the [ __ ] you're supposed
to say
uh everybody was speaking that ordering
that and i was just like i
am at the spot and i could tell i could
tell i was like this [ __ ] place has
been here forever
this is one of these places where you
know
all families would come you could tell
by the seating and all that [ __ ]
and i got myself a nice chicken burrito
and i gotta tell you
i wanted it to be great i wanted it i'm
like this is the real [ __ ] deal
right i'm like the only white dude in
here this has to be the real [ __ ]
you know and i i ate it and i got to be
honest with you it was
solid it wasn't great it was solid it
was a it was a
solid b give it a b
all right a being the best b being not
quite the best
solid b it's not a c c is like
it was a b it was good
all right but when i when i was growing
up every restaurant was a bee
it was a couple of super [ __ ] fancy
places that mobsters owned or some [ __ ]
but you never went to that crap when you
had a family
every [ __ ] place was like that place
i went to today and i kind of been going
to those
so me and my wife we have like um
i'm gonna go back there and bring the
wife and kids like that's a great like
you know plenty of places you know they
have this nice outdoor patio
people were distanced and whatever and
uh
i don't i like going to places like that
i'm not into the [ __ ]
the chains or whatever but you know i do
order [ __ ] from amazon
whatever i'm not a perfect person all
right and if you don't believe it now
let's listen to me read out loud and
you'll know
immediately how flawed a human being i
am all right we're going to start
we're going to start today with little
zip
dad grow up
zip recruiter everybody you know
businesses
have had to be flexible this year from
working remotely to pivoting their
business models for long-term survival
and growth
how have you had to readjust your
business well i do stand up in parking
lots now
now when i drive down the street and i
see a patch of grass
i don't think wait how come they haven't
put a house there yet i look at it and
say you know what's a great place to do
a stand-up comedy show
restaurants are moving their dining
outdoors and adding takeout and catering
i've noticed that major retailers are
now
selling face masks um
if you're in charge of hiring for your
business
these pivots have had you have made your
job even more challenging
especially if you had to hire for brand
new roles
thankfully there's one place that you
can always count on to make hiring
faster and easier
zip recruiter
dot com when you post a job on zip
[Music]
it up it gets sent out to over 100 top
job boards with one click
then zip recruiter's powerful technology
finds people
with the right skills and experience for
your job and actively invites them to
apply it's no wonder
four to five employers
who post on zip
get a quality candidate within the first
day see for yourself
right now you can try ziprecruiter for
free at ziprecruiter.com
that's it dot com slash burr
spell out bar b-u-r-r let's zip
recruiter take hiring off your plate so
you can focus on you growing your
business go to ziprecruiter.com that's
it
dot com slash burp the smartest way to
hire crew smartest way to hire all right
indochito indochina innocino
you know having clothes that fit just
right can be a huge
confidence booster describe any
particular issue you often run into when
shopping for clothing yeah with my suits
you know if i wear the wrong socks
occasionally when i wear a suit when you
sit down all of a sudden you're showing
like you know three inches of leg
and you just say whatever you're
pitching at that point it's just [ __ ]
over
right example wishing sleeves were a
little bit longer
being a smedium etc no i just talked to
you having socks that are too short
indochino was started on the belief that
custom clothing shouldn't cost a fortune
talk about the convenience of i don't
want to [ __ ] talk about [ __ ] tell me
what i'm supposed to say
weddings and other special occasions
talk about this what am i [ __ ]
working in the the fashion district talk
about buttons
weddings and other special occasions
are a time to make unforgettable
memories and look your absolute best yes
i agree with that
give your wardrobe a style upgrade
within doccino
get made to measure clothing at great
prices including suits
blazers shirts and coats you get to
customize everything from the fabric and
lining to the lapel shape and monogram
you got to love a monogram
that says i'm a man i'm running my
business
all right and if you'd like to come home
with me sweetheart i will dick you
down all right the choice is all yours
your clothing is
made to your exact measurement so it
fits you perfectly indochino's black
friday event
incoming is now this is the best time to
buy as they're offering their lowest
prices of the year including custom
suits for just
289 dollars with the promo code bur burr
you'll save an extra 30 bucks on any
purchase of 3.99 or more
you can shop online at indochino.com
that's a safe way to take advantage on
black friday
do it online or visit any indochito
showroom that's indochino.com
i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o
indo chino dot-com promo code bir
b-u-r-r
all right what's next oh we got simply
safe
simply safe something everyone wants to
be
you know everyone wants to keep their
home and family safe whether it's from a
break-in
a fire flooding an annoying neighbor
or a medical emergency simply save home
security delivers award-winning 24 7
protection
with simply safe you don't just get an
arsenal of cameras and sensors
you get the best professional monitors
in the business they got you back day
and night
ready to send the cops fire or emts when
you need them most
straight to your door uh simply safe has
an
arsenal of sensors and cameras that
protect every inch of your home you can
set it up yourself in about 30 minutes
it's super easy
then simply safe professionals take over
monitoring your home
24 7 and ready to send help the moment
there's an alarm
plus simply say with simply safe there's
no long-term contracts no hidden fees or
installation costs right now my
listeners get free
a free home security camera when you
purchase a simply safe system
at simply safe.com you also get a
60-day risk-free trial so there's
nothing to lose
visit simplysafe.com for your free
security camera today
that's simply safe s-i-m-p-l-i
s-a-f-e simply with an i
there you go well oh billy [ __ ] game
film
watched another couple uh i watched the
rest of that bills
seahawks game and my super bowl pick in
the west
the uh seattle seahawks i didn't realize
that evidently they have like the worst
defense in the [ __ ] league
jesus christ letting up 44 goddamn
points
having said that they still put up 34 in
the bills
so um i don't know what the takeaway on
that game is i will tell you this though
russell wilson's ability to extend the
play
to use a cliched sports uh and uh
euphemism whatever the [ __ ] you call it
the way a guy can scramble around back
there and his receivers just keep
getting open and then
on the run the deep ball accuracy
that guy that [ __ ] one play where he
was running all around and then this one
guy just ran all the way to the end zone
like 50 yards away
and he just hurled the ball looked like
doug flutie when he was playing against
uh the university of may
the u way back in the day right just
fires this [ __ ] thing
the guy was was way in the end zone
there was another guy like 30 yards away
on the bills like sprinting down trying
to get the guy
he caught it like a punt um it was
amazing but i'll tell you what else was
amazing was was the uh the play calling
um and um
by the by the buffalo bills and they
just shredded that [ __ ] defense for
44 goddamn points
and uh very impressive and also another
great game that i watched
over the last couple days i watched kyla
murray
uh the arizona cardinals really fun team
to watch
um even though that kenyan drake dude is
out
they played the miami dolphins miami
dolphins showing a lot of hat they got
that shack whatever guy on defense
up front was causing a bunch of problems
and uh oh that's another thing of the
bills game the amount of times they
sacked russell wilson was crazy
which made me look up hey how many sacks
do the patriots have we have like
[ __ ]
we played like eight or nine games i
think we have like four or five sacks
as a team um whatever this is all [ __ ]
this is a transitional year
that's all all right everybody [ __ ]
relax so
um i gotta say uh
i don't know dolphins that was an
impressive [ __ ] wing and that kicker
came out man
50 yarder no problem right there fred go
[ __ ] yourself
but um if you got the nfl package man i
definitely suggest
taping the uh arizona cardinals
that kyler murray is something else
just to watch watch him when he's young
because you can't run around like that
for too long at the quarterback position
and that guy is like
you know sometimes only the first down
he's he's diving headfirst and [ __ ] so
um i don't know that's the fastest
quarterback i've seen probably since
michael vick you know i saw michael vick
like pre getting busted with the dogs
in atlanta at the georgia dome uh
the most electrifying football player
i ever saw live um
i mean every time he was if he even
thought about running the entire [ __ ]
stadium stood up
um although i did see i saw randy moss
when he was on the vikings i saw him at
the hubert humphrey
uh metro dome
um that was a good one too
i've seen a few but i would have to say
michael vick just because he had the
ball
every offensive play it was in his hands
and he had no idea what the guy was
gonna do
um anyway so that is it um
so there you go liberals
all right just just ask people on the
right
nicely ask them to comply you understand
these are people that fix their own [ __ ]
these are people there's a reason they
live out there
they don't want to be [ __ ] with so
don't ram your [ __ ]
down their goddamn throats okay
just because you live here doesn't mean
you're smarter than them and vice versa
there's a lot of great things about
living in the middle of nowhere you can
go out on your porch
sit there completely naked looking at
the [ __ ] stars
you live in the city you got to have
your clothes on you're going to get
arrested
and then you can't see the stars because
of the glow of the city you know and i
think that's one to grow on
all right that's it everybody go [ __ ]
yourselves have a great weekend you
[ __ ] and i will check in on you on
monday
wait who i mean i'll i'll see you on
monday who do the patriots have this
week
after a big victory oh i didn't even
talk about that honda up against the
[ __ ] jets man
how different a team are the new york
jets
with joe flacco the guy's only got a
super bowl ring
he's sitting behind this sam darnold who
puts the darn
in darnold right they drafted him in
2018 gave a bunch of guaranteed money so
they [ __ ] keep that kid in there and
all of a sudden joe flacco comes in
starts picking apart our tattered
defense and i got to tell you man it was
great seeing cam newton
lead us back to a victory and not have
to
run and jeopardize hurting himself um
what's his face who's the biggest he had
a career day for us
i just went blank on his name it's the
same name as a [ __ ] uh
um law firm there
jacoby meyer right jacoby meyer that's
right jacobymeyer
he had a big day um
so there's some positives there you know
we [ __ ] right in that game with the
buffalo bills i don't think we're as bad
as people think that we are
and i think it's um
when a belichick's i i just you know
it's what he's doing with what
he has okay i would like to see all
these other [ __ ] i don't know there's
that [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] rex ryan said
[ __ ] jealous guy just a [ __ ]
jealous guy who just bugs me
all right can't can't how about they're
both great
how about that um all right that's it
that's the podcast i had to get that
enjoy the music and now there's going to
be a bonus episode of the monday morning
thursday afternoon just before friday
monday morning podcast from a couple
years ago
put in there the music and the episode
are both picked out
by the great andrew themillis all right
that's it i'll talk to you later
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday
uh november 12th um oh billy freckleface
is off the road
for the first time in a while first time
in a while and i have to tell you i i
don't know what to do with myself
it's phenomenal i wake up on my own bed
you know
although i do feel estranged
from the lovely nia you know we haven't
seen much of each other
i'm just kidding that word is never used
it's always used
when um a couple breaks up estranged
you know like you're never estranged
from a family pet
right do they ever say that on the news
mel gibson and his estranged dalmatian
were seen
trying to reconcile
um you don't do you
you know bill you could always just look
words up and just figure out what they
mean rather than just trying to figure
them out how people use them
do you realize how many words there are
in the english language that um
i know how to use them but i could not
give you a definition
i just keep hearing people say him you
know like when you listen to some dude
from the [ __ ] hood
back in the day first time you heard
that's dope and you're like
that's dope he's a dope heard that
is he saying it's stupid
i you know and then you just gradually
think oh it means something good
why do they do that why do they make it
mean
the exact opposite why is this some sort
of passive-aggressive way to frustrate
white people because of all the [ __ ]
we've done to them
oh jesus i don't know and you go back up
with your white friends
whether words make sense to you you know
um anyways this is the monday morning
podcast where the [ __ ] did my dog go
cleo cleo
there you are i thought you started i
thought you figured out how to open a
door
that would be a problem now that i've
called you and you think i'm going to
give you attention
beat it all right thanks for the kiss
okay
anyways this is the monday morning
podcast if i haven't said it 87
[ __ ] times yet um as promised last
week i said you know what
i'm gonna do ari shafir skeptic tank and
you know what i'm a man of my word even
though i still can't pronounce that
skeptic tank um i did it at the comedy
store it was great we did it right out
there on the patio and uh
there's a bunch of tour buses keep
coming up so we keep getting interrupted
by the public
and i got to tell you like nine tour
buses came up
full of tourists not one of them
recognized me
and i'm gonna tell you bruce my ego
you know well that's funny but i'm dead
serious
i was i wanted that moment to be hey
bill hey
that's that guy from the thing i really
like what you do
i wanted that to happen i'm not ashamed
of that why the [ __ ] you think i got in
this business
why do you think i get on the goddamn
stage and dance like a [ __ ] monkey
every night
because i want to improve your day no
it's all about me all about me and my
credits
um anyways what a week
huh people what a week of [ __ ] stress
my apologies to everybody out there in
the red states i know you wanted uh
uh what the [ __ ] is his name mitt romney
his real name willard
willard mitt romney starting at powered
forward
from some white land you never heard of
number 26 willa
admit romney
um you know i actually saw something
with uh
lord of the rings actually watched a
little bit of that [ __ ]
i watched it for i think about 20
seconds
it was the white-haired dude with the
guy who looks like ricky schroeder if
ricky schroeder got [ __ ] by spock
ah sorry i like that one um
and i was standing there and of course
there's some broad there who like you're
supposed to respect but for
no [ __ ] reason at all she's showing
way too much skin
you know does everybody in like middle
earth in like
in the future and in the past they all
have [ __ ] bikinis on with like a
sword or some sort of knife
when can that error be in the present
that's what they should do that's what
you [ __ ] should be doing
when you go down to the beach with your
little skimpy outfit on you should have
a nice [ __ ] uh
daniel boone knife in there
and then all the [ __ ] the the the the
i don't want to say players but i don't
know what else to say the guys who know
how to talk to [ __ ] women will leave
you alone because they see the knife
but there's a price there's always a
price to pay you'll have a bunch of
[ __ ]
nerds following you because they'll
think you're uh
i don't know why the word willow's
coming into my head is that one of those
references
you know i found out the other day that
led zeppelin was really into uh lord of
the rings
i didn't realize that when they were
singing about all that [ __ ] cause in the
darkest
depth of mortar is that from [ __ ] uh
lord of the rings
you know i bet it's a wonderful book
you know it's just that you got to sit
down and read all three of them
oh my god what's gonna happen next are
they gonna
are they gonna get up to the surface or
they're gonna go down towards the the
heated core
of the earth middle earth and what
there's a [ __ ] sun down there that
doesn't a nerd realize
even nerds should know that right
anyway so i'm watching this [ __ ] for
like 20 seconds
i'm like i'm gonna give it a shot here
i'm gonna try
you know or at the very least get a
couple more references for my podcast
and i'm sitting there right
and the old the obi-wan kenobi looking
guy talking to
uh ricky schroeder who got [ __ ] by
spock and the lady
with their [ __ ] bikini and her knife
i don't know if she had that i'm
probably thinking of princess leia when
she was next to that fat [ __ ] toad
when boba fett got killed right and um
all of a sudden this white horse comes
in
all white horse comes in and uh
and the ricky schroeder who got [ __ ]
by spark is like
i don't know what he said what if is up
with vadath i don't know what he said
and the [ __ ] obi-wan kenobi guy goes
oh that's so and so the lord of all
horses
[Laughter]
it was how do you watch past that line
is that really the lord of all horses
you [ __ ]
senile old coot what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you and not to mention
subtly racist why is the lord of all
horses
is white as [ __ ] chalk huh coming up
with good hair
mane just flowing
how kind of how come it couldn't been
like one of those arabian horses you
know jet black with the sun shining off
the side
seeing all the muscles you know
there you hear the hair first i think
that the [ __ ]
i think it's a little racist
why isn't all white horse the lord of
all horses
is that racist to do that our other
horses and like ponies
you know horses and ponies would never
get along
black horses would make in front of the
point with their ponies oh this little
[ __ ]
[Applause]
oh jesus um anyways
i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm talking
about i just thought it was ridiculous
the lord of all horses and you're
sitting there eating your popcorn
and your [ __ ] reese's piece he's just
eating that [ __ ] up
you know i saw a couple i actually saw a
couple and went out and i saw i
go i saw that
and um i liked it but it was funny when
ben affleck
they say what's your name and he goes my
name is tony mendez
i remember thinking in my head going
mendes
i think that's a latino name
i know it's not a white name i know i've
never met anybody
i never met a white guy hey what's your
name uh larry
larry what rodriguez larry mendez it's
not
you know it's not like one of those
crossover names so in the end of the
movie
spoiler alert they had this is just [ __ ]
in the credits
they just have uh you know they have a
picture
of everybody you know each cast because
this was a true story so each cast
member
is um you know i should talk to this i
should talk to nia about this
you know what that's this is it um we're
gonna do a [ __ ] uh
another neolog this week and i'm going
to talk about this because
they had you know the six actors who
were [ __ ] unreal who played the uh
the people trying to get out of iran
they showed a close-up picture of the
actor right next to a close-up picture
of like the photo id
of the person that they were playing and
it was [ __ ] dead on
they looked exactly like the person and
then there's like another minute or so
of credits
and then they finally show the real tony
mendez and the picture
is like a full body shot of the guy from
like halfway across the room shaking
hands with jimmy carter
and you're looking at the guy and he
looks like bartolo colon's dad
and me and nia just started laughing our
asses off
and you know it was it was one of those
moments one of those hollywood moments
and then i looked on the internet and
there was people complaining going what
the [ __ ]
you know how come you couldn't get a
latin actor to do it
and all that [ __ ] you know
this is what i got to say about that i
definitely think it's [ __ ] up
why didn't i just say what i had to say
about say about that like
like what i'm just gonna present all
this [ __ ] and then move on
all right i don't know how to say my
points without having some sort of intro
and now here is what i think about that
i think it's [ __ ] up because it was a
real dude and he's a hero
he did some unreal [ __ ] so because it's
a real
dude who did some real heroic [ __ ] you
should have a latin dude
play the guy so everybody knows that
that win
is in their column you know that's one
for latinos
you know so the next time you get into a
bar room argument
you know well do we invented the
airplane
and then the latin guy could be like
yeah well we're the ones who got those
six [ __ ] on the plane and got
him into canada
right and all of your [ __ ]
both sides you're in a bar so none of
you read it's all based on the movies
but now that's going to cause a fight in
a bar
because someone's going no you didn't it
was a white guy
no it was [ __ ] tony mendez essay
he said [ __ ] you then why was it played
by ben affleck and then there's gonna be
a big fight
but on the other side is if you got a
[ __ ] million dollars
and you you need the movie to sell what
do you do
i still think they should they should
have gone they should have got louise
guzman
no jesus louise guzman is
tony mendez i don't [ __ ] know you
know what that's one of the ones i got
to talk to nia about that [ __ ] but it's
it's a good movie you should definitely
go see it
but i got to tell you that was
inadvertently [ __ ] hilarious
um like me and nia walked out and
started joking about it and by the time
we got out of the movie theater we were
crying laughing and everybody
was looking at us like we were out of
our minds we went to this one of those
we went to one of those [ __ ] malls i
hate going to you know those new malls
that they make where they try to make it
look like this little city
where there's no crime and everybody
gets along you know i don't just mean
like a mall we got you know the big
anchor stores and then they put a
[ __ ] bunch of [ __ ] in the middle of
it i mean what it's like outside
and they have like a trolley and a water
fountain
and they're playing like big bad music
you know like that that
that frank sinatra music and tony
bennett music that makes you feel
successful even if you're failing you
know you're just walking around
just buying a bunch of [ __ ] you don't
even [ __ ] need
and yeah you know but it all feels right
because tony bennett's in the background
if i ruled the world
every day would be the first day of
spring
and you're [ __ ] walking in and out of
like lucky jeans
you know what are you doing
what are you doing they're building the
big [ __ ] house for the fake guy to
sit in there and for you to put your
[ __ ] kid on his lap
right or maybe the talking bunny
that time of year there's a big fountain
and it [ __ ] shoots off water right
to the music you know what i mean
there's everything
other than like animals that don't get
along with each other playing
you know like they always did that like
the [ __ ] disney movies
they start rolling around each other you
know doing somersaults with leaves and
butterflies and everybody's like
giggling and laughing just having a
great [ __ ] time
like that's what nature is
you know it isn't it's like one of those
[ __ ] prison shows
locked down somebody's getting shanked
somebody's getting killed every [ __ ]
day out there
you ever wonder that why don't they ever
part why don't they ever post the murder
rates out in the woods
you know why because they'd be off the
charts and there's nothing you can
[ __ ] do about it that's why there's
no mayor in the woods
you know you can't help it you just let
the that
you just let people sort it out that
right there you look at the [ __ ] not
the woods the wilderness
all right let's take it up a notch the
woods that's like high school level
football this is the pros
all right that's how it goes you got the
woods a wooded area
right then you have like a uh a parcel
of land
that's like the college level division
one and then the wilderness that's the
[ __ ] pros
you know there's no society
there's no [ __ ] rules
anybody can blow anybody away
that's how that works there's no trials
you know like that [ __ ] all those people
went through out there in jersey and
still going through with that [ __ ]
hurricane
that [ __ ] new jersey became the
wilderness
you know a couple of days everybody's
nice hey i like your gas can
is yours empty too right
[ __ ] three days in four days in
forget it
everybody starts getting that coyote
look in their eye it's over
[ __ ] over you know i swear to god
i sat here in my house
watching some of that [ __ ] thinking what
the [ __ ] am i gonna do
when inevitably some giant earthquake
out here in los angeles hits and we're
just up to our [ __ ] armpits
what am i gonna do know
i started thinking about all the people
who came to my door
during halloween you know they got their
little masks on and stuff they're all
giggly and happy and that type of [ __ ]
and they got their parents kind of in
the background you know
you know what i realized those [ __ ]
are coming back this time they're
wearing masks for a different reason
and they ain't coming for the candy
[ __ ]
um no seriously what the [ __ ] am i going
to do
so i started watching that show you know
what those people who are are
prepping for doomsday and you're
supposed to watch that show
and i guess laugh at these people on
some level and
i had to shut it off after 15 minutes
and i was just like this guy
is right this guy is smart what he's
doing is smart
it's smart to prepare for doomsday not
even doomsday just for something [ __ ]
up to happen
because there's too many people
and uh i think it's dumb to basically
just be [ __ ] sitting here and your
your
your whole game plan is um i'm all good
if it's all good
hey what if chaos happens well then i
guess i'm [ __ ]
that's what i've learned so i'm sitting
here and i'm watching these guys and
they're building these these things in
the ground
and uh you know where they can stick
food and all this type of [ __ ] or
survive stuff and all that and i i don't
have the space for that
i can't do it so all i can do is go out
and i'm gonna get two guns one
for those [ __ ] [ __ ] coming up the
walk and then
my safety my backup gun
the one when all hope is lost and i eat
that last fruit loop i just put it to my
head
[Laughter]
you know i would be ready
there's no you know i'm too [ __ ] old
to learn green beret
jiu jitsu how to grow [ __ ]
plants and i'm just i'm too [ __ ] old
i'm too set in my goddamn ways
all right i like i like you know i'm one
of those guys i don't wait for the sales
you know what i mean that's my mentality
i need a coat i just go out and i go
[ __ ] buy one
all right i'm going quick here i'm
getting a gun i'm shooting at people who
are coming at me
and when i get down to my last bullet
i'm a [ __ ] idiot why don't i just
have one gun
save some extra money just have one gun
you get down to the last because i'll
[ __ ] it up that's why
click click click click click and then i
had nothing left and then when the
zombies are coming in what am i gonna do
just start smashing myself in the head
with it
oh this podcast it's always so uplifting
isn't it um
so anyways and with that let's do a
little advertising here
on the uh the monday morning podcast
what the [ __ ] is
it um all right here we go stamps.com
everybody
all right some small companies think
some small companies think that leasing
leasing a postage meter is how business
gets put
what is how business get postage for
their letters and packages
oh businesses why don't i just wing this
because i try and read the copy
it makes them sound dumb they wrote that
sentence correctly by the way it said
some small companies
that think leasing a post-its meter
is how businesses get postage for their
letters and packages
that isn't how they do it but they don't
realize that there's a better way
stamps.com everybody you don't want to
go to the post office anymore stamps.com
is the way to go
unlike a postage meter stamps.com has no
hidden fees
like meter ink charges or reset fees no
long-term contracts
no extra hardware to buy or lease
stamps.com can save you up to 80
compared to a postage meter plus with
stamps.com you can do
more than you can with the meter uh you
can use your existing
address book send tracking information
to receipts with with the click of a
button
the choice is clear stamps.com offers
more features
at a fraction of the cost i use
stamps.com to send out all my dvds when
i go out on the road
it's easy and if i can figure it out so
can you so just use my last name burp
b-u-r-r
for my special offer notice risk trial
plus 110
bonus offer includes a digital scale and
up to 55
dollars free postage um don't wait go to
stamps.com now
stamps.com now before you do anything
else click on the microphone at the top
of the homepage type in burr burr that's
stamp.com
enter bur b-u-r-r there you go
there you go do you guys watch sports
this weekend
or were you reading about the lord the
lord of all horses
um whiter than an albino
would you get an all-white horse first
of all it wouldn't be all white it would
smell like [ __ ] [ __ ] after a while
it just it'd be like having a white coat
you know you can't you can't lean up
against anything
you know you know p did he always has
those all white parties but what they
never do is they never show the
the patrons at the end of the night you
know with their [ __ ] red wine
spills all over them and god knows
whether whatever [ __ ] hedonistic [ __ ]
happens on those parties
um does he still have those would i just
make a [ __ ] reference to something
from 10 years ago
um anyways you guys watch the you watch
the election
i didn't watch any of it i was actually
terrified of the results
you know what i mean i i didn't like
either one of those guys
and each one of them had some [ __ ] that
i was afraid if they got elected was
gonna happen
um i line up with a lot of republican
[ __ ]
surprise surprise but uh i can't you
know if they would just drop that
and if somebody's a witch we should be
allowed to stone them
you know those guys really gotta [ __ ]
you know and being gay is a choice
like that [ __ ] it's just in the world's
flat and then the
the sun goes around the earth like that
[ __ ] it's
i mean how many votes does that how many
votes would they [ __ ] lose
if they dropped those jesus freak
psychos
you know it's one of those things where
sometimes it's almost like rebuilding a
team where sometimes you just got to
take a step backwards you just got to
get rid of that old guy
you know and moving moving with some new
[ __ ] and just just wait
patiently for that person to start to
learn the game
you know i don't [ __ ] know
i don't know because at the end of the
day whether you elect the democratic guy
the republican guy
those [ __ ] [ __ ] are still going to
saw the tops off of the mountains
you know they're going to still dump
[ __ ] in the ocean
the banks are still going to do what
they do
you know i talked to a guy yesterday who
used to work for goldman sachs as a
waiter
i'm like what do you mean as a [ __ ]
waiter he used to work at the top
floor this is how bankers are living he
said up at the top floor
these guys they had the best china the
best civil war these bankers every day
for [ __ ] lunch
and they would just have these insane
meals and on the walls they had like
rembrandts
just for their own enjoyment and this is
a great thing that's
all our money that we go down there
and give to those [ __ ] banking
is it's the most evil [ __ ] thing i
think on the planet
due to my limited knowledge and how some
guy just told me he was a waiter at
goldman sachs and he seemed to have all
the details i took
everything that he had to say at 100
percent face value
um yeah it's just that's
you know i don't [ __ ] yep you know
something the amount of times i open my
mouth
and by the time i realize what i'm
talking about i'm just so far
over my head it's ridiculous let's get
back into my wheelhouse did you guys
watch any football yesterday you watched
the football
hey how about how about texas a m beat
in alabama
huh i was a week early alabama
the dream is over no the dream ends
tonight
the dream ends tonight and you know why
you're probably sitting there
has anybody seen this kid at johnny uh
manziel
huh johnny football is there calling him
this [ __ ] guy's unreal
he's running around like mike vick and
he's and he can throw the ball
on the run he can stay in the pocket the
kid's a freshman
i hope he doesn't get hurt the way he's
running around like he does
he's going to get killed in the nfl if
he tries to do that but he's only a
freshman and it seems like he can stand
in the pocket
granted i have not watched one [ __ ]
game um that he's played i've just
watched his highlight reel which is the
youtube video of the week
texas a m johnny manziel i hope i'm
saying his name right no disrespect
um his highlights you got to watch this
guy
and uh if you don't watch college
football
and you want to jump in at some point
this would be a great guy to watch
um as you you watch him through his
career hopefully he'll play at least
three years but if he keeps doing what
he's doing he's probably gonna bail
after his junior year right sophomore
juniors and then what the kids do
nowadays
um and they lost and
i was too busy freaking out i was
actually an artist actually doing i was
trying to do some uh
boyfriend girlfriend [ __ ] here because
i'd been on the road so much
someone said it say
as they say in boston come on over and
say
fried d or say um
the hell did we do we went out
to this asian cuisine place because
she's freaking out because they had
these ramen noodles and not the broken
broke broke ass [ __ ] like the real the
real [ __ ]
you know from like behind the wall of
china i believe is where they come from
i don't [ __ ] know
and uh i go there i'm not a big noodles
guy
you know what i mean i don't like
slurping that soup with all those
[ __ ] noodles i always i just
you know if it's raining out you know
i'm kind of a soup guy i guess
i i just i just don't like it but she
wants to go i want to go i want to try
to hurt that good
so all right let's go so we went there
it was actually was decent
you know i got pork in mine
you should have seen this slab of pork i
swear to god if i ever have a heart
attack
instead of my life flashing before my
eyes it's going to be that piece of pork
going that's what it was and then i'm
gonna [ __ ] land face down
in my spaghettios like that fat [ __ ]
seven
right um so we did that
and then we went over and we saw argo
and uh and i figured you know i figured
i was done for the night
for the day i figured i was done and
then she mentions to me
that uh you know somebody she know is
having a
uh a housewarming party
do you want to go to that and i was like
no
no i don't i have no desire why would i
want to go there and then i just saw the
look on her face and i was like all
right i'll go
i'll go and i went down there i actually
had a great time
actually had a great [ __ ] time but
it's you know when you go to a
housewarming party though
you know it just i don't know you
[ __ ] go there and you're like oh wow
they have one of those we should get one
of those
honey how come we don't have one of
those and it ends up just costing you
money
you know so i would recommend because
the place we went they had a really nice
house
if you agree as a guy to go to a
housewarming party
only go if you know your house is better
because if you don't your girl's going
to see some [ __ ]
or you're going to see some [ __ ] you're
going to want it and next thing you know
you're going to [ __ ]
you're going to you're going to want to
buy it you know
i don't know somebody already gave me
[ __ ] came into my house was just like
dude when are you gonna like officially
move into your house i'm like i am in my
house
you know and he kind of made a couple
more [ __ ] comments and uh
i don't know i guess what you're
supposed to buy the house and rather
than pay down the mortgage you're
supposed to buy a bunch of shiny [ __ ]
like every other [ __ ] [ __ ] on the
block
you know yeah i don't have a i sort of
have a dining room table
and yes we don't have any chairs yet
all right i'll buy i'll buy the [ __ ]
chairs
when when when i got the the
the principal down to a point where i
can [ __ ] relax at night
that's how i do it i get the [ __ ]
house
i keep my air mattress or whatever the
[ __ ] i buy and i just pay the thing off
and then once i pay it off
then you buy the chairs then oh
we want another tv then you get the
other [ __ ] tv
these [ __ ] [ __ ] lighting up their
credit cards
and paying all the [ __ ] interest
they're at the top they're at the top of
the building
with the finest china with rembrandts on
the wall
and you know why that is you know why
that is
i don't even i don't know i don't know
why it is i had to say you know why that
is twice because i actually don't even
know why it is
okay but i'm gonna try and buy as few
paintings on that [ __ ] wall
as humanly possible i'm gonna pay these
[ __ ] back
you think i'm [ __ ] sitting here on
the hook for 30 goddamn years
you're crazy all right and if i have to
have a dining room table
with no [ __ ] chairs if that's the
price i have to pay
well then god damn it i'm doing it all
right that's what i say
and you go [ __ ] yourself if you don't
like it you know you want to come over
for thanksgiving come on over
all right wear some comfy shoes because
you're going to be standing up with
paper plates
all right and when you give me that look
i'll [ __ ] break out my mortgage
and i'll [ __ ] put it right in your
face and show you how what percentage i
owe
how i'm knocking it down how i'm giving
it a [ __ ] liver punch every month
that's what i'm doing
all right anyways i'm just [ __ ] with
you guys um i'm not actually
the anger's [ __ ] but the philosophy
the philosophy's intact um
anyways how about those new england
patriots huh no jesus
good lord i swear to god if it wasn't if
we didn't get 3000 yards
in penalties in favor of us um i i'm
gonna say you know
but you know something the bills didn't
deserve to win that game anyways it's
like
they almost have like a fear of winning
every time they were gonna win oh my god
we're gonna score a touchdown let's drop
the ball on the one yard line
hey we're down by six if we score a
touchdown here
we'll actually win the game throw it to
the other guy
i swear to god this is uh you know this
patriots team right now
is like basically what i've been
watching for the last four years where
our record is way better than our team
like we have to score 35 to 38 points a
game
just for me to feel comfortable as a fan
and then we let up like you know
anywhere from like 24 to 31
33 points but at the end of the year
somehow we're 11 and 5
12 and 4 and 17 point favorites in the
playoffs and then when we lose people
like that absolutely
shocking it's like really
what numbers are you looking at what
games are you what games are you
watching
um i actually think our our
i like our front four and i don't mind
our linebackers but our secondary
is uh as my mom would say leaves
something to be desired
jesus christ they make every [ __ ]
quarterback who comes in look like joe
montana we don't have
one lights out guy like even if the
rules of coverage
were that were uh the way they were
before peyton manning and the colts
complained
and spearheaded this movement now where
if you even i mean
how bad what were some of those past
interference calls last week
of this past week i should say that
first one they called on the bills they
basically gave
the patriots a touchdown the second one
i guess you could say was past
interference because he just impeded the
guy
as he was trying to cut across the end
zone but even that one
back in the day was kind of iffy
and uh i don't know i don't like it
i don't like it and i didn't like when
we tackled their quarterback and it
evidently it was
our fault that he was so short that when
our linebackers stood up they went face
mask to face masks you know when that
that [ __ ]
fits patrick that look of anger he had
on his face like he can't believe he
just tackled me
throw the flag you know the whole brady
rule
you know i love how [ __ ] dumb
football fans are too where they they
actually blame
tom brady for that one that that's the
nfl
okay brady and his uggs makes the nfl
a ton of [ __ ] money and it and they
lose a bunch of money
if he's on the sideline okay so that's
basically
straight across the board it wasn't good
for the nfl last year when peyton
manning was out it's not good when
brady's out it's not one good one drew
brees
um aaron rodgers any of these guys are
out so they're completely over
protecting them
all right but it took tom brady captain
america to go down for them to realize
it that's basically what it was
that was the straw that broke the camel
back and if you [ __ ] want to blame them
huh well you go ahead and blame them but
i know the real it's a money it's a
money decision
that's what it is the whole [ __ ]
thing
is all about you know what what are
people who are
casual fans of the nfl like they like
offense
they like scoring every [ __ ] rule
all right i'm a broken record you know
what i'm saying it's just another sunday
of just like
i literally at this point when i watch a
game even if if it's
my team has the ball if i see a flag
during a pass play
i just immediately go ah that's [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and people laugh they go you haven't
even seen yet it's like i don't need to
see it eighty percent of them are
complete horseshit
you see what they did there he was
covering the receiver
you can't do that you can't do that he
he
reached he his fingernail
brushed the sleeve of the wide receiver
right there you can't do that after two
and a half
yards um
i had a [ __ ] panic attack
the lakers fired their coach mike brown
and i loved mike brown
i loved everything that he was doing for
the lakers
[Laughter]
i loved you guys all know i hate the
lakers i totally respect
kobe bryant i respect the showtime
lakers
i actually love all those players now
now that they're retired and everything
and i watch the highlight i just you
know i can now just sit back
and be like man those guys could they
could really play the game
and i love all the laker fans that were
there back in the day at the forum all
right
but there's new [ __ ] it's a different
kind of hate like i'm not a lady i hated
the lakers back in the day
but um i hated the team and it was the
same basically the same team every year
after year for the most part
that core group of guys was the same
group of guys but this this [ __ ] [ __ ]
now
you know with everybody just piling on
like dwight howard dwight howard
blew up that team out there in orlando
the guy was a [ __ ] cancer
he drove his [ __ ] coach out of town
they faced the lakers in the finals
he's posting up against like [ __ ] uh
pau gasol or was it bynum i don't
[ __ ] know
but you know all of those guys should
have been in foul trouble with how big
the
body he was and he didn't do [ __ ] he
didn't do [ __ ]
so now what does he do he joins the
[ __ ] lakers
he's dancing with ellen and everybody's
acting like this guy's this [ __ ]
savior
right so they come in there they're not
winning [ __ ]
blame it on mike brown he gets [ __ ]
bounced out which he should have he
should have fired him after last year
they should have fired him that time
when kobe walked back to the bench and
went to high five him
and kobe completely blew him off right
there he's lost the team
but you never know with kobe you know
what i mean
you know that guy he's always [ __ ]
but i respect what he does he just wants
to [ __ ] win if you suck
he doesn't try and hide it he will
embarrass you on tv and i guess he's
he's earned the [ __ ] right to do that
okay
i'm being pretty even-handed here for a
celtics fan you got you got to give me
that all right
all right there person with the laker
flag flapping in the wind as you drive
down the street
um so anyways they fire mike brown and
then i hear
that they're talking to [ __ ] phil
jackson and i
i can't even tell you how [ __ ]
depressed i was
when i heard that phil jackson jack
jackson jackson
would possibly be coming back to the
lakers i it was
it was the same hopeless feeling i have
when i watch baseball
where it's the fact that there's no
salary cap in baseball
like hoping that the yankees are going
to suck it's just never going to happen
again they got too much [ __ ] money
although the red sox have demonstrated
that you can spend 180 million and still
suck
um and come in the last place which i
believe we did
but and i know what you're thinking
you're like well the [ __ ]
nba has has a salary cap they don't have
a hard cap
they have a salary cap this is the
salary cap but you can go beyond it and
if you have enough [ __ ] money
you can [ __ ] uh you know you can
grease some palms and will allow you to
put together these juggernaut [ __ ]
horseshit [ __ ] [ __ ] championship
teams or i should say
uh new breed of championship teams all
right
like i don't think
a lot of these championship teams like
it just kills me that these guys
just pile on now and then you get your
ring
which is fine because i guess that's the
way it's done nowadays
but the fact that you then put on espn
and they start bringing up guys like
bill russell larry bird
magic johnson you know
all these [ __ ] greats who stuck with
their team
you know and a lot of them didn't get
their [ __ ] rings
you you earned a ring back in the day
that's all i'm saying this [ __ ] now it
this is like the time out generation
type [ __ ] you know where everybody gets
a [ __ ] ribbon
so i'm sitting there thinking like oh my
god they're gonna get phil jackson i was
like oh my god
they're gonna get they're gonna get phil
jackson
and dwight howard who blew up a [ __ ]
team
choked in the finals got his coach
[ __ ] fired is now gonna get a ring
and those [ __ ] [ __ ] on espn go where
does this put him
they're going in the lineage of great
laker centers
kareem they would actually mention him
in the same breath
as kareem and shaq
you know wilt [ __ ] chamberlain and it
just it drives me nuts
do you realize the lakers have never had
a [ __ ] great center
that was theirs do you understand that
they have been buying centers
around the league like paris hilton
getting shoes
their entire [ __ ] lives none of their
great centers were there guys
will chamberlain you know he played on
like every [ __ ] team evidently he was
a piece of work
um i think what he did was he [ __ ]
every chick in the city when he was done
he switched teams
so um kareem they got from the bucks
shack they got from orlando and
obviously uh dwight howard they get from
[ __ ] orlando and it's just it's like
watching a [ __ ] rich kid
you know whatever you know oh i just
cracked up my corvette
you know you're like oh good now he's
got to take the bus and no daddy and
mommy buy him a new one he drives
you know drives to school with it the
next [ __ ] day
so i'm psyched that phil jackson didn't
come back
it just kills me that like that that
that franchise is so [ __ ] insane
that they had they have phil jackson on
speed dial to come in whenever they have
a [ __ ] problem
like harvey keitel and pulp fiction he's
like the cleaner like he's just gonna
come in
oh my god we lost four games in a row
call up phil jackson it's like i'm
saying they go well why the [ __ ] don't
the celtics call we got you know
we have a coach i'm just saying
i don't [ __ ] know um i am happy that
celtics got a little bit younger
but um this is going to kill me when the
lakers
pass the celtics and championships
because they're gonna do it
because uh they
people just wanna why wouldn't you wanna
play out here beautiful weather
[ __ ] celebrities dance with ellen you
know
how the [ __ ] are the celtics going to
compete with that
that's cold eight months of the year and
then it gets unbearably hot
no celebrities and
yeah we got good lobster
lobster um
i don't know i don't [ __ ] know and i
swear to god if one more [ __ ] laker
fan
brings up the [ __ ] you know celtics
championship with the big three
and it's like well you guys did i i
realized we did it
and i've said it a zillion times we
bought a championship that year
all right it didn't feel the same as
when we won in the [ __ ] 80s
all right but you guys are doing this
[ __ ]
year in and [ __ ] year out
it's just just racking up these [ __ ]
championships going around the league
picking up free agents like you're some
fat [ __ ] at a salad bar
you know it just kills me
it [ __ ] kills me that this is how
you're gonna do it
what can we do in boston to compete with
[ __ ] la
you know what i would do this is what
who's kidding who the
the basket basketball is like what like
90 percent
african-american all right so right
there you have to somehow make
boston a city that an african-american
is going
to want to live in all right and uh
if you want to like we don't we don't
get good ratings with that crowd
[Laughter]
i'm going to go out on a limb and say a
lot of people uh a lot of people
african-americans do not have any
interest to go to boston to check out
the freedom trail
or paul revere's house considering the
stories that they've heard about that
city
you know it's funny that boston gets
such a bad reputation for being racist
where you know
like as opposed to what la with their
great racial uh harmony that they have
out here
every time the lakers win a championship
it's like they're happy for five minutes
before they start
trying to like kill police officers
tipping over
[ __ ] cruisers and all that type of
[ __ ]
you know the last unbelievable race riot
in this [ __ ] country was here
the filthiness of the lapd and all that
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you know allegedly killed biggie
had [ __ ] gang members in there i mean
i don't [ __ ] know
but for some reason i know the [ __ ]
reason but i'm just saying we that's
still hanging around our [ __ ] neck
like an albatross
the average black person if you say
boston what's the first thing you know
about it
they say it's it's it's a racist city
that's basically what to hear so that's
what the [ __ ] we're working on
in this new era of going out and buying
championships you notice lebron didn't
even swing by where the [ __ ] we were at
you know
um so this is what i would do
as far as the black people i know you
know
if you start talking conspiracy
conspiracy theory
they're they're on board not all of them
but a lot of them
so what i would do is i would basically
i would make
the zeitgeist of los angeles i would
show them that film
and then and then take them on the
freedom trail i would just show
la falling into the ocean after some
epic [ __ ] uh
uh you know that big earthquake that's
supposed to come
you know and then the footage that i
would use to show like
how it's on fire and all that type of
[ __ ] would be the rodney king riots
and um and then to ease all this type of
[ __ ] i would be playing that song that i
love la
i love l.a and then you cut to rodney
king getting the [ __ ] kicked out of them
you know what i mean and all their awful
cops and i would just show every [ __ ]
bad [ __ ] about them and then i'd have a
scientist come in
talk about how many people are out there
versus how much actual
water is being piped into this [ __ ]
city i'd show video footage of how the
colorado river does not reach the ocean
anymore
and uh yeah that's what i would do
i would make a hollywood movie to trash
hollywood
and then i i would just show them like
lake winnipesaukee
up in uh
up in new hampshire i would just let's
just say listen the dollar's about ready
to crash
we've taken out too much debt you know
you want to be where the trees are where
the fresh water is
we'll build you your own fallout shelter
with a full court full nba court uh uh
inside of it
and whatever your favorite junk food is
that we'll [ __ ] have like
20 refrigerators looking like mtv cribs
you know you'll be able to ride out any
storm and then you come out
and we start the league again with 80
percent less people living in this
country
after the fallout right does that sound
like a plan
anybody from the celtics organization is
listening i am available
um all right let's get to the uh
let's get to the uh the this is gonna be
a long podcast this week because i'm
already 47 minutes in and i'm just
getting to the uh the stories and the
questions here all right uh alcohol
hiccups
last week i mentioned that i had uh
almost terminal hiccups
after the lsu game and just basically
i'm surprised i didn't get gout the way
i what i did to my body last weekend
um anyways so this guy says here hey
bill sorry to hear about the hiccups at
the lsu game
those special ones that don't go away
are the worst i've suffered from bad
acid reflux since i was in college and
i'm 35
now so i've tried about every remedy out
there and i've learned a lot about it
uh the hiccups you get when you're drunk
and have been eating all day are extra
horrible
because they do not go away no matter
what you do i've had nights
i've had nights out ruined by this yeah
you can't hit on some chick if you got
the [ __ ] hiccups
um he said i had nights ruined by this
until i finally figured it out
i doubt you'll see this advice on any
website most people who never experience
this will tell you
to take something for it or do something
that would cure
regular everyday hiccups it won't work
the last thing you need to do to a
stomach that's full
and that's screwed up is add something
else to it yeah because that's what i
was doing i was trying to hold my nose
and drink
water um he says if you ever get hiccups
like that
if it happens again find an out of the
way place
uh or or not
take your finger and gently touch your
tonsils
until you puke you need to get that evil
out of you it's the only way as long as
you don't drink too much more after that
i'm supposed to keep drinking after that
supposed to run behind a dumpster like a
[ __ ] bulimic and then keep drinking
all right
i'm gonna be open-minded here he goes
your hiccups will be gone
and you can go on with your night
shouting at college kids or whatever you
feel like doing
um all right i'm sure that that does
work
because i guess you're getting all the
[ __ ] uh
[ __ ] out of your stomach that i mean i
don't i don't want to
but the fact that you would then you're
like get that evil out of your stomach
so then you can put more evil into it
that's like getting out of a bad
relationship
and then going out and dating another
psycho
you know do you know when i actually
when i got rid of the hiccups is what i
did was i came home
and i just started eating right and i
stopped putting evil in my stomach and i
was fine
but um i would i would probably say what
you want to do
is yeah stop eating and then the next
time you get hungry i would have like a
salad
maybe some lemon water something really
easy on the stomach
and i would think that they would go
away naturally but i guess if you're in
a pinch i i don't
ever i don't ever like promote going out
and puking and then you're basically
like a a
you're like a partying bulimic where
bulimic will go out and eat like fudge
and cake and all that [ __ ] they're not
supposed to have on a pizza and then go
out and puke it up
you're doing that i guess with like
alcohol and potato skins
um interesting theory
i'm sure it works but i i i'm not
willing to pay the price but thank you
for uh for trying to help i'm just i'm
just gonna try not to
slam five michael lobes and then eat
like [ __ ]
a sausage king a burger and some sort of
po boy sandwich
all within like uh two hours
i think i had some scotch in there too i
can't remember oh jameson
anyways here we go bill from the
military
um i have faithfully served in the
military for five years now
i currently have three years left to go
on my list enlistment jesus dude
don't you re-up after four so i guess
that's what you did
there's no eight-year enlistment is
there
do you start as a sergeant um let me
preface my dilemma by saying that i love
the military
it has provided me with opportunities i
wouldn't have never dreamed of
it got me out of the dead end life that
i was living in my po dunk texas town
i've been to places and experiences
experienced things that i never would
have thought possible before
i made so many great friends and bonds
that will land last a lifetime
now within the past couple years i've
come to the realization that we
in the military are just pawns for these
corporate scum [ __ ] to make a buck
we go to war for money and resource
control
people think that we're fighting for
freedom or anybody
people that think we're fighting for
freedom or anybody else's freedom either
has their head up their ass
or they are just uninformed i'm sure you
know this
all of this already so i will save you
the rant there are ways i can get out of
my enlistment early and maintain an
honorable
status now with the war drums beating
for iran like they did for iraq almost a
decade ago
do i try and get out early and risk
feeling like a coward and a [ __ ] for
the rest of my life
or do i stay in and risk dying or
watching friends dies for a cause i no
longer believe in
sincerely anonymous military member
um
yeah well the first thing i would say is
when uh
when you're presenting your opinions
all of it's great but if you say people
who don't get it
you should just say don't have access to
the information they need
when you go have their head up their ass
anybody who's just listening to this is
now immediately like pulling back
um yeah look
uh i can't argue with any of that you
know i don't think you're a coward if
you don't re-up you already fought in a
war
you know what i mean if you don't
believe in it yeah i would i would
definitely get out
i mean as far as this last thing i mean
i was all about go get osama bin laden
okay i'm believing what you're telling
me that he was behind those attacks
we need to go in there and go get that
[ __ ] guy but i never for once
believed that we were going to iraq
to try and liberate those people you
know
i mean [ __ ] the corporations of
government they don't give a [ __ ] about
people who live here why would they give
a [ __ ] about people over there they
don't give a [ __ ]
give a flying [ __ ] i i totally agree
with that
all right saddam hussein was our guy and
we didn't give a [ __ ] what he was doing
as long as he was doing what we want him
to do and then when he didn't
and he started going rogue you know we
uh
all of a sudden we're like hey this bad
guy that we're in business with is a bad
guy
he's evil for some reason we didn't
notice that for the first 15 [ __ ]
years we were in business with him
whatever the [ __ ] it was first 10 years
when did we put him in i always get
confused was it like in the 70s or
something
yeah like he gassed his people and we
didn't get outraged you know enough to
do something for like another [ __ ]
eight years i mean
i you know i i don't [ __ ] know i i
my experience that i've learned from
traveling is that that people are people
you know we're just uh you know the
average person
is not evil you know they're walking
around that they they want to they want
a job they want to be able to provide
for their family and they want to find
uh true love
that's all they really want they don't
want to control other people and all
that it's just
it's i don't know what would you say 15
of of the population is uh sociopaths is
it higher than that
those are the people i don't know
this is too depressing to talk topic to
discuss i would get out
okay you're lucky enough to survive you
did your duty just if you don't believe
in it anymore
you know and who can [ __ ] question
you that you can question me and say
that i'm full of [ __ ] i'm some [ __ ]
jackass who never went
you know sitting here you can definitely
trash me but you if you're there and
that's what you're seeing and that's
what your gut
is telling you you gotta act on it
that's what i would say
all right that's what i did say
um yeah that shit's just too [ __ ]
depressing
i hate seeing that i hate seeing like i
hate listening to rhetoric
that's trying to make me afraid of other
[ __ ] people
they're gonna do this they're gonna do
that they're gonna do this they're gonna
do that that's exactly what the [ __ ]
they're saying over there they're gonna
do this they're gonna do that they did
this they did that and then everybody
gets all [ __ ]
amped up you know and then this is this
is completely unoriginal
thought everybody knows this and then
the [ __ ] who gets everybody all stirred
up they don't [ __ ] do [ __ ] they sit
back
and watch everybody they got all stirred
up and then they they hope that their
team [ __ ] wins
um yeah so i would get out
i would get out i mean yeah it takes
balls to get out
to say [ __ ] this don't give in to that
peer pressure you're
you already did it you already did it
all right i'm just keep saying the same
thing over and over again so yeah
yeah all right animal control officer mr
burr
i'm a big fan and i caught your show in
cincinnati uh
in october you killed it thanks for the
laughs i'm an animal control officer in
kentucky
and i have been and have been for two
years the job is really getting me down
lately
i have to euthanize animals this used to
not be a problem for me because i felt
it was not
a necessary evil jesus christ are these
gonna be the most depressing [ __ ]
emails ever ah here we go
i deal with some of the lowest people on
the planet i'm starting to hate people
i would rather put down the low life
owners than the poor [ __ ] animals
that didn't get a fair shot
wow somebody uh you know that's [ __ ]
that should be in a movie somebody just
snapping in an animal shelter
yeah hey hold it down hold down spot you
know and you get them to hold them down
and then you [ __ ] stick it in their
neck
they have that you know that great
confused look somebody has when they
realize that they're being killed and
the tables turned
in movies it's one of my favorite scenes
in those movies but wait
i made you um
anyways um i come home mentally drained
in the animal control community they
call it compassion fatigue
oh god in another life i really want to
go the corporate route because i just
want to be in a room when they're
pitching
like what what can we call this
um
doggy dts
no no that dts that's too much like uh
addiction
then somebody comes up with compassion
fatigue and they actually get a [ __ ]
high five
and they all go out and get a taco salad
they have a [ __ ] idiot
um plus i work for my micromanaging [ __ ]
the pay is pretty good for my area of
the world and i have really good
benefits
my problem is i got offered a [ __ ] job
making less money with less benefits
the job will require me to travel more
which is great for me
i just have a problem walking away from
the cash and the benefits
i have a son so i want to provide as
best as possible for him but i feel like
i should take my happiness
into consideration also help me out here
walk and be happier or stay and make
more money
uh thanks for the podcast go [ __ ]
yourself
uh p.s do you get tired of people
telling you to go [ __ ] yourself
um ah no not really now that you just
said that i guess it's getting a little
old
um anyways but then again i say it at
the end of every [ __ ] one i don't
know
where am i what the [ __ ] are you talking
about um
look i would walk and choose happiness
you'll be a happier dad
all a kid really [ __ ] wants he wants
to know that he's he's safe and that
he's loved
all right and you know there's a bunch
of kids out there who have ipads and all
that [ __ ] crap
and their dad's never around i swear to
god you know what the greatest thing
when i was a kid was when my dad had
time to go out in the backyard and throw
the [ __ ] ball around
if you just do that i don't give a [ __ ]
where you're living you know and we had
up
up and down financial times when i was
growing up we had a house we lost the
house moved into a duplex
you know but i still had a great time
you know
i still had a [ __ ] great time so kids
your kid isn't gonna know that you're
making less money unless you're making
like [ __ ] 700 grand a year
to uh put dogs down and then you go to
making 30 grand a year
but um you're fine
you're fine i would think i would choose
happiness
all right so there you go once again
another question
in way over my head i was never in the
military i don't have a son
you know so take that with a grain of
salt anyways wife's weird sex store
purchase oh
geez here we go
wife's weird um dear bill me and my wife
have been married for two months and she
has been less involved and willing to
have sex
all right right there and she got a
weird sex store purchase
i don't need to read the rest of this
sir have it annulled
um anyways he goes i thought the
honeymoon phase was just ending
and started to adapt it's been two weeks
since we last had sex and friday
while taking out the garbage i found a
bag
to the local sex shop okay
that's it i don't need to read any more
just get it annulled go your separate
way
i didn't know what she bought and since
we haven't been having sex
it was a puzzler okay that's it
this whole [ __ ] thing it's over
i then started snooping okay that's it
while she was at work and found a dildo
in the closet
i know women have them but this one
wasn't your usual dildo
okay that's it nothing to see here
dude this has more red flags than the
than the [ __ ]
opening ceremony of china at the
olympics
okay it wasn't your usual dildo jumping
back in
we're losing a lot of tiles i think
we're going to burn up here and [ __ ]
re-entry
um it was the shape
of an animal's penis ah alrighty
see you later that lady it was a fun two
months
i i'm not even you can keep everything
i'm just gonna take my t-shirts and my
shoes
and a pair of pants it was close to a
foot long and weirdly shaped
wait a minute they don't make animal
dildos
what does an animal penis even look like
i don't even i've seen an elephant [ __ ]
it's the scariest thing i've ever seen
in my life
seen dogs bang
anyways it was close to a foot long and
weirdly shaped
i have kept quiet but i really want to
confront her but don't know how to do it
without hurting her feelings
or opening a crazy can of worms please
help bill
all right dude you know
you you nee you need if you're not just
gonna walk
you really need professional help on
this one
all right
i mean how i don't know what what do you
do do you take the thing out of the
trash
and then just leave it on the [ __ ]
coffee table and then she walks in
and just you're just pacing hey honey
how was your day
and you just [ __ ] what what's this i
just found this in the [ __ ] trash
huh which orifice were you shoving this
in i mean there's no [ __ ] way to how
do you even bring that up
listen dude i'm going to tell you this
right now your wife
has a huge dildo now
your wife has a your wife has a huge
skeleton something there's something
gigantic going on oh god i can't
got to stop saying gigantic and huge
she's got a big secret bigger than that
[ __ ] giraffe dildo you found in the
[ __ ] garbage
um
you're two months in dude and you're
already not getting
sex is already a [ __ ] issue all right
now it sounds like you really love this
woman the fact that you're actually
still willing to work this out
but as an outsider with no feelings
no no heart no broken heart on the line
here
um
you know i think you just gotta walk
i get no you know what i i
what would i say i would just say i'm
literally sitting here right now guys
and i'm i'm
rubbing my eyes you know when you do
that with one hand you know that move
i'm doing that right now trying to think
of how to [ __ ] how do i bring this up
i would take the [ __ ] hippo [ __ ]
and i would i would put it in one of
those
uh big brown bags if it can fit from
macy's whatever you got to do
maybe like one of those you know when
they plastic wrap like a christmas tree
i would find one of those bags
and i'd stick it in that and i would
just say
honey i need to talk to you about
something all right and i would sit it
down dude
[ __ ] this and [ __ ] her [ __ ] feelings
all right i see i had to get past the
shock here
all right just sit her down and say
listen
i'm not judging you i'm i
i you know i just need some honesty here
because
this is a gigantic huge
[ __ ] gorilla dick that i found it's
trash
okay you haven't been having sex with me
what is going on what is just tell me
what is going on
i'm not going to tell anybody about this
other than this podcast
i'm not going to judge you just level
with me
do you is this why you want to go to the
zoo
the other day no just you got to get it
out there dude you got to get it out
there and you have to
hear her [ __ ] story and you have to
be supportive
both for her feelings and for you for
the fact that you deserve to know the
[ __ ] truth about this before you
spend the rest of your life with
somebody who's gonna bang you once every
two months
while secretly wanting to [ __ ] a tiger
or whatever a [ __ ] grizzly bear
dude there's no they don't make animal
dildos
and i swear to god you [ __ ] [ __ ]
if there is a website don't send me the
link because i'm not looking at it i
don't need that on my hard drive i'm not
looking at it
dude you have to sit it down okay
and and you you have to bring you got to
bring in that zebra dick
you just you have to do it
you got to do it you got to do it
you owe it to yourself all right and as
much as it's going to be embarrassing
for her and everything
it's going to help her out because i bet
that there's a part of her that she
she doesn't like herself that she's
sneaking around and starting to live
this lie and all or
or whatever the [ __ ] is going on
i don't know i would also bring maybe
bring it to the sex store and ask
somebody what this is
before like you make a complete ass of
yourself because god knows what if it's
something else what if it's like a
[ __ ] uh
you know you know those wood things
that's on an old staircase
um i don't [ __ ] know uh all right on
a banister
um all right hey here's a classic we're
bringing back that i had to drop because
i think uh
daniel tosh already did uh is it racist
thing but this falls under the category
of is it
racist racist racist racist racism
um all right here's this guy okay
man this [ __ ] has been bothering me for
about a week and i can't let it go
i work at a national laboratory with a
lot of employees
a lot a-l-a-l-l-o-t a lot
of employees everyone in between
ranging from the dorky phd scientists
with no skills to the janitor and
groundskeeper
two words who's usually
are either immigrants or just ged
uneducated people
anyways i am a pretty social guy who
walks who talks to everyone
and gets along with most uh i've been
working here for eight years
and know a lot of people a-l-l-o-t of
people here
it's a-l-o-t um well
there is this janitor dude
named montez if the name didn't give it
away he is black
and i myself are are pretty
white okay montez doesn't strike me as a
black guy's name and your grammar is
terrible
uh not shockingly caucasian as yourself
but pretty close
well i thought i was kind of friends
with montez as i would frequently
[ __ ] with him at work throughout the
years
i've been working here until just last
week
all right so basically you're a
scientist with this [ __ ] bad grammar
um anyways this is smoking hot young
girl who that was hired about a year ago
a 21 year old deliciously young black
girl named
patricia all right deliciously made it
creepy um
at my work at my work of scientists
there are a lot of good-looking women in
the building
so any good-looking chick gets noticed
so she was going to school to be a nurse
and for whatever personal reasons
she quit school she works as a janitor
oh so she works as a janitor there the
deliciously young black girl
um so last week i'm bullshitting with
montez and i'm asking
him where his partner is referring to
patricia
he asked me who i respond the young girl
who was going to school to be a nurse
and he goes and i don't know what
possessed me but i added in the
conversation
that girl that girl shouldn't have quit
school
it's stupid to just quit as it only
takes a few years to rough that [ __ ] out
and then you have a degree and nobody
can take it from you
uh this is when montez got pissed off he
says to me
don't call my friend stupid and he says
i'm like what
uh shut the [ __ ] up man she should oh
you're like i'm like what shut the [ __ ]
up man she should have finished school
don't you agree
otherwise she's stuck here being a
janitor with no education
and you said this to a janitor ah that's
a good move
uh but if she graduates she can move
anywhere and still have that
that piece of paper blah blah blah he
spells peace p
i p-a-i-c-e
um this guy's bitching about this other
okay he replies
not if she don't want to be a nurse what
if she wants to be a janu
janitor i followed
followed what that's [ __ ] up if it was
your own daughter wouldn't you want her
to finish school
now he's all sorts of pissed off he
makes comments about how you'll be happy
on wednesday won't you
referring to the election i think he was
taking a shot at me and assuming i
wanted romney in office
i realized he had just pulled the race
card and i can't believe it
after insulting him and what he does for
a living um
he goes i asked him i asked him are you
[ __ ] serious
he gets all thug and tries staring at me
with this hate
acting all hard like he wants to fight
me we're both 40 plus years old
all the while there are people near us
who are starting who hear us
starting to argue fighting is not
acceptable at work
not even arguing especially about a race
issue it's not politically correct and
all that [ __ ]
um if this were high school we would
have been fighting but i'm 42 years old
and have a mortgage in a career etc this
dude is also about 5 foot 10 180 and i'm
a lot bigger than him
so what do i do i apologize to him dude
if i said something to piss you off i
didn't mean it and i apologize
he continues being a dick to where i
tell him i apologize
once [ __ ] and that [ __ ] is not
gonna happen again
and now i'm getting pissed off and
people start to stare and i have to walk
away but before i do i tell him under my
breath
that he's a stupid [ __ ] and go
clean some [ __ ] jesus christ dude
then he goes what did i do wrong there
other than the parting shot i gave him i
can't stop thinking about it i mean i
like the guy and that's what pisses me
off about it most
am i [ __ ] racist or is it him
uh i don't think i said anything out of
out of line
but maybe i did before telling this to
[ __ ] off that is i'm gonna see this
[ __ ] at work
and i have a hard time with letting
things go but my job is more important
just wanted your advice is it me
uh dude actually
i don't know if you're racist but you're
you're you're an idiot
you're an idiot you walked up to a
janitor
and you basically you belittled what he
did for a living
before you even said why don't you go
clean some [ __ ]
all right and you also didn't take into
consideration
that it could have been like uh
financial reasons why she quit
you know who knows who knows why she
[ __ ] quit
it doesn't make sense that someone would
quit nursing
to then go up and and be a janitor
so right there you should have [ __ ]
left it alone that usually means some
sort of [ __ ] drama happened who the
[ __ ] knows what happened
something happened there could be a
zillion
[ __ ] scenarios as to why she became
ended up being uh working there as a
janitor
all right and you're saying to a janitor
who at this point is in his 40s
he's still a [ __ ] janitor he's taking
pride in what the [ __ ] he's doing
you know people [ __ ] on janitors all the
[ __ ] time
he knows that anybody who goes around
cleaning up [ __ ]
they know what people are going to be
saying you know you're supposed to treat
everybody with [ __ ] respect and you
didn't
so look what you're saying is right but
you said it to the wrong guy
you know if you had a daughter you
wouldn't want to quit nursing school
then become a janitor you wouldn't
but you don't [ __ ] say that to a
janitor you know and
you're also kind of a creep where you're
sitting there saying she's a deliciously
young black girl
i'm gonna say that there's some more
[ __ ] going on with you
and uh why were you act asking why where
this delicious
first of all you're [ __ ] 42 [ __ ]
years old you should be looking at some
21 year old girl like she's delicious
you [ __ ] creep sorry this took me a
minute dude you're [ __ ] creep
and you're a [ __ ] and you're allegedly
a scientist and you can't even spell
so i don't even i don't know what you do
over there
this is bad right now because now i'm
insulting you and you're not going to
learn anything from this [ __ ] like dude
all right here's some rules you never
make fun of what somebody does for a
living
all right and i'm not going to judge you
because i did that one time i got into a
fight with somebody and he was a
bartender
and um i was working the club and the
guy was in the middle of washing glasses
and i was we've gotten this [ __ ]
argument about sports
red sox yankee [ __ ] and i said ah go
wash a [ __ ] glass
not realizing that i i didn't mean it
like i was belittling what the [ __ ] he
did
he was just washing glasses so i said it
and i and he [ __ ] like was ready to
stab me
and i actually
someone told me later dude you can't
[ __ ] say that [ __ ] and i was like i
didn't mean it that way [ __ ]
once i got on my ego i learned i was
like all right i can't do that
and dude you can't sit there at your
level you're in
economic level above this [ __ ] guy
although the way you're spelled you know
i don't know you can't do that dude you
you
i don't know if you're gonna get it but
like
to say that [ __ ] in the end to call say
that he's dumb
and then say go go [ __ ] clean
something like but
i don't know that's one of those things
where it just escalated and then he got
your grill and he's [ __ ] acting like
he's gonna kick the [ __ ] out of you
and then you got mad so then you said
that [ __ ]
and then he gets to think you see that
you were thinking that [ __ ] the whole
[ __ ] time
which you probably weren't right until
then
you know so what you basically did is
you ruined the next 60 white people
that black dude is going to run into
because he's going to keep thinking
about you
so um
this is the deal that's some [ __ ] you
can't apologize for like you guys are
never gonna be friends again
um but you still should apologize
i don't know and then what's he gonna do
act like he's gonna kick the [ __ ] out of
you and then it's gonna
[ __ ] i mean i think it might be a rap
just might be a [ __ ] rap i don't know
i felt halfway through that i was
trashing him for being a [ __ ] janitor
you know what did we learn there people
don't make fun of a janitor
don't make fun of of somebody being a
janitor to a janitor
because they're going to get mad
[Laughter]
i don't know about you dude you're a
creep
you're a creep look i'm not gonna sit
there and act like as a 44 year old guy
you know
i don't see a girl in her 20s and if
she's [ __ ] gorgeous you know
but i always address that i'm 44 years
old
i always address it like if i'm with
somebody
but i'm with somebody like we make a
joke about how [ __ ] old we are
or something like that but the older i
get the more i start thinking like why
would you dress like that don't you
realize the [ __ ] [ __ ] you're gonna
be attracting to you you know there's
something about that word deliciously
it's just absolutely [ __ ] disgusting
and i feel
i i think you're a creep
at some level you're that [ __ ] guy
that ruins it you know
you're the one that takes it into that
creepy [ __ ] area then and it's just
such a creep that you make the person
you're with feel like a [ __ ] pervert
you know
uh i don't know who the [ __ ] knows all
right that's the podcast for this week
um i am in connecticut
oh billy
i wanted to hint hint hint
um wait a second where the [ __ ] is my
website
my website by the way billboard.com if
you'd like to go to that
oh and if you want to you know help
support the troops
amazon.com all you do is go to the my
podcast page if you click on the podcast
page you'll see a link to go to
amazon.com and if you buy something they
give me up they give me they kick me
back a little bit of money and then i
take that money and i take a little bit
of that and give it to the wounded
warriors project
all right that's what i do that's what i
do
here on the podcast so anyways shows
this is where i'm gonna be i'm gonna be
at southern connecticut university
and uh that's open to both students and
the public
so if you live in connecticut and you'd
like to go to southern connecticut
university and watch me do my [ __ ] i'd
appreciate it
and uh that's november 17th
which is what's today the 12th that's
five days away tuesday wednesday
thursday friday that's a saturday
and then i'll be at the brea improv in
brea california november 30th december
1st
and 2nd that is the deal
um yeah that's it that's the podcast go
[ __ ] yourselves have a great week
you